it's a real honor to be here this
afternoon and it's especially exciting
for me to learn that if you play a
character with a certain career long
enough people will treat you as if you
actually have that job so this might be
a shocker but I am actually not a deputy
director of Parks and Recreation but
raise your hand if you are one here if
you work in the parks recreation
department here I've met yay
congratulations to you um you guys are
easy to spot but I'm very happy to be
able to play at parks and rec employee
because parks play a vital role in our
lives it's where our families gather and
our communities come together just ask
yourself this question without parks
where would we put all the swings
it would be in the middle of the road
there'd be very dangerous this is so fun
mrs. Obama's standing next to me like
she's my my audience and I'm just
telling her jokes it's like a dream
except for the money except for the box
which is a little embarrassing isn't it
but I have to stand on that but I'm a
grown woman standing on a box okay but
the let's move initiative is is so
wonderful getting kids outside and
challenging them to be physically active
is a great cause and let's move is such
an amazing initiative it's taking off a
little bit faster than my initiative
let's help me move it's not going as
well but I'm so pleased to be here among
you find people it's an honor truly to
represent the Parks and Recreation
Department even fictionally and I
apologize if we did anything to smear
your name but um you do all you do such
good work I'm so happy to be joining
everyone here and so without further ado
ladies and gentlemen the First Lady of
the United States and my best friend I
just said that on the record and it
makes it true mrs. Michelle Obama
that's good it makes a good seat well
done well done well hello everyone and I
want to thank Amy for being such a good
sport and for her very kind introduction
and for her let's help me move
initiative it's good to bring a little
bit of that Pawnee spice down here to
Miami so let's give Amy a round of
applause and yes we are best friends I'm
coming over to your house I want you to
cook me something to eat you do cook
lean meats whole grains vegetables you
may have heard yes okay i also want to
start by thanking a few other people i
want to thank representative for drika
wilson who is here love her love her
thank you for joining us and thank you
for her leadership for the state and for
our country I also want to thank Barbara
Damon and Larry for their remarks as
well as everyone from the Boys and Girls
Clubs of America I want to thank the
National Recreation and Park Association
the partnership for a healthier America
and the Alliance for a healthier
generation thanks to all of you for the
outstanding work you do on behalf of
millions of families across this country
but really most of all I want to thank
all of you the community leaders the
program administrators the coaches the
educators the parents who were working
so hard to build healthier families and
communities every single day and this
week as we mark the fourth anniversary
of Let's Move we're recognizing and
celebrating folks like you who are doing
their part to help our kids grow up
healthy in fact just this morning I was
at the White House talking about the
amazing strides that we've made in our
schools from serving more nutritious
breakfast and lunches to finding new
ways to get kids moving through our
let's move active Schools Initiative and
by the way I want to give a
big big congratulations to miami-dade
county for signing up every single one
of your schools for let's move active
schools I think that yeah round of
applause well done so proud of you all
and today with this new announcement
from the Boys and Girls Clubs and from
NRP a millions more kids will be in
healthy environments and not just during
the school day but during those critical
hours after school as well and this is a
big deal because for so many kids
there's still that two or three hour gap
after the school bell rings a gap when
their lives aren't as structured and
parents don't always know who they're
hanging out with how they're spending
that time or for that matter what kind
of food they're putting into their
bodies and for so many years after
school programs like the Boys and Girls
Clubs and the NRP a have done the vital
work of filling that gap by giving these
kids a place to go a place where they
can learn new skills and explore new
interests a place where they can get
help with homework and guidance on the
challenges they're facing in their lives
and today these programs are realizing
that healthy eating and physical
activity are critically important parts
of these efforts that's why with these
new commitments kids will be getting
fruit or vegetable at every meal and
every snack they'll be drinking healthy
beverages like water and low-fat milk
and they'll be getting active they're
going to be moving around at least 30
minutes a day and over the next five
years with the support of the Alliance
for a healthier generation these new
changes will be implemented in thousands
of after-school programs across the
country and when you add that to the
ymca's previous commitment to make their
after-school programs healthier the
result is that this effort could reach
more than 5.5 million young people
nationwide
so this is going to make up yes it's
going to make a huge impact it really is
and not just on our kids health but on
their success in school and in life
because everybody here knows that kids
who eat well and stay active tend to
have better grades they have better
attendance they have fewer disciplinary
problems at school and between today's
announcement and our work to serve
better food and get more active activity
into the school day we're now ensuring
that more and more of our kids will be
staying healthy throughout the entire
arc of their day and if we just think
about this for a minute we have revamped
our school meal programs so soon
millions more kids will be starting
their day with a healthy meal and then
they'll get another get meal at lunch a
meal that includes more fruits and
vegetables and whole grains then they'll
be getting active through the school day
whether that's during resets PE class or
doing an exercise break between lessons
then when school is out they'll head to
an after school program like this one
and they'll get even more nutritious
food and even more opportunities to get
moving and that's not just good for kids
that's also good for parents because
while parents still have to do their
part at home to cook healthy at home and
turn off the TV and make sure their kids
are moving they'll know that all their
hard work isn't being undermined every
time their kids head off to school yeah
yeah I we got some moms in there and
some dads
and that's what let's move has always
been about it's always been about doing
everything we can to make it easier for
parents to raise healthy kids and what
you all are doing here in Miami is a
perfect example of this kind of work
you're showing kids that you don't have
to be the world's greatest athlete you
don't have to be on a varsity sports
team just to get physical activity
that's why you've got kids doing some
great stuff they are kayaking and
canoeing they're taking hikes out in
nature you've got them playing tennis
and running track and your stocking your
vending machines with healthy snacks
you're starting community gardens to
teach the kids about healthy habits and
after just one school year with these
changes in place you've seen physical
fitness scores go up you've seen kids
improve their understanding of good
nutrition habits and kids themselves are
giving your programs great reviews so
everybody wins kids are happier and
healthier and parents can breathe just a
little easier and that's why today I
want to challenge everyone who works
with young people after school to follow
your example and I know it won't be easy
all of you here in Miami can attest that
big changes don't happen overnight and I
know that many after-school programs are
operating on tight budgets but time and
again we have seen that with enough
creativity and commitment and teamwork
we can truly transform our communities
on behalf of our kids and really that's
been the story of let's move from the
beginning we've seen that change is
contagious and it adds up quickly and a
day after just four years healthy habits
are now becoming the new norm in so many
parts of our lives just think of all the
changes we've seen restaurants are
investing millions of marketing dollars
to promote low-calorie menus food
companies are cutting sugar salt and fat
from their products child care centers
are offering healthy snacks
meals and instead of plopping little
ones in front of the TV they're making
sure they're playing and running around
and soon millions more kids will be
attending healthy after school programs
every single day and make no mistake
about it all of this is starting to have
a positive effect listen to this today
the CDC announced that obesity rates
among young children have dropped to
eight point four percent that's the
lowest rate we have seen in a very long
time
so we're beginning to make some real
progress and none of this happened by
accident it happened because of people
like you because people like you were
willing to take a stand for America's
families and communities and I know that
this kind of work is happening all
across the country and I wish I could
personally visit every school and after
school program or go to every community
in America to see all the changes that
are happening but that's not humanly
possible so instead here's the thing to
the millions of you who are out there
every day working to create healthier
communities for our kids I am asking you
to show me how you move all right it's a
little bit of a challenge I want to hear
from everyone I want to hear from
schools and daycare centers and
households I want to see what after
school programs are doing all across the
country I want to see those new snacks
you're serving the fun games you're
playing and the gardens you're growing
and I want you to tweet it Facebook it
Instagram it with the hashtag let's move
so that everyone can see how you and
your communities are moving toward a
healthier future we are getting
thousands of entries in already and as I
said earlier if we get enough entries in
we might get a little surprise from the
president maybe the vice president could
be interesting this is a fun and
exciting way to share best practices and
learn about all the good work going on
to create a new norm for the way our
kids eat and stay active and I can't
wait to see all the great things that
you're doing and remember if we all keep
moving and we keep doing our part just
like all of you here in Miami then I
know that we'll be able to give our
children the bright healthy futures they
deserve so congratulations and thank you
so much I'm going to come down and shake
hands and then we're going to get moving
you guys thank you so much
you